everybody and Fabio I recently joined
the faculty of the University of padova
italy i want to thank the organizers for
giving me the opportunity to present
some recent work that I've done with the
student of mine the teas in Denmark
because i was in denmark until six
months ago i want to thank all of you
for being here after lunch usually the
toughest talk so i'm going to try to
keep you awake anyway so if you have
questions just jump in at any moment ok
so i'm going to talk about an algorithm
that we've developed developed to find
sub-networks letter mutations
significantly associated with the
survival in cancer but before starting
to talk about survival let me review
some of the things that we have already
seen in the talks yesterday and also
this morning and in particular what
we've seen is that a nowadays we are
able to measure somatic mutations in
many patients of a given cancer type and
there are at least two large projects
that are doing that for thousands or
tens of thousands of patients and one of
the main goals is to identify driver
mutations using all this data so we want
to defy the mutations important for
cancer so one of the ways that is used
the most is to use a single gene test to
identify such significant mutations so
one can look at each gene one after the
other and for example counting on many
patients it is mutated compare this
number with a probability distribution
that that is given when we have not
driver mutations in the genes and then
by correcting for multiple hypotheses
because we are considering many genes
one can identify a small number of genes
that are significantly mutated and these
are the driver genes as whether the just
before lunch there are other driver
genes that probably appear in the
low-frequency mutated genes and one of
the reasons why this gene have low
frequency of mutations is because we
actually need to look at jeans and
mutations in the contest in the
context of networks since cancer is a
disease that is driven by pathways so
our goal action is to identify the
pathways the set of genes that are
significantly mutated and one approach
will be just to look at known pathways
known set of genes and for each set of
gene County know many patients it is
mutated and we can just generalize the
approach that we use for single genes
use the multiple hypothesis testing on
this set and we may able to identify
some set of genes the problem with this
approach is that not all pathways are
known and there are other problems and
so what we want to do actually is to
move away from using non pathways and
try to identify new set of genes that
are important for cancer so our question
is out can we find significantly mutated
set of genes with others directing to
non-parties the way problem is that
there are many candidates said if we
want to look at all of them and in
recent years many methods have been
proposed to try to identify important
set of genes in cancer without having to
essentially look at all the possible
candidate so while I was compiling the
list of all the metals I saw that
actually couldn't fit all of them in the
slide so what I've decided to do taking
inspiration from speaker from yesterday
is to just decide to not put any of the
previous methods here and let's talk
about two classes of metals the type
contributed to the first one is the
class of metals that actually have been
presented by Max just before lunch that
look for patterns of exclusivity among
mutations in the second class of methods
are matters that try to combine an
interaction network with mutations to
identify the significantly mutated sub
networks and they were contributed to
this with the method called hartnett and
with this improvement attitude that is
joint work with a mac slicers okay so
why did I present this because I want to
make the point that by moving from
single gene test to actually looking a
set of genes we can identify
low-frequency genes or genes that may
have a low score by themselves
and by pulling them together in sets we
may be able to identify more genes that
are significant from cards for cancer
okay so in many studies for example from
the TCGA in addition to the mutation
data we also have survival information
so for each patient we are given a
survival time and so another natural
question when we have this data is
trying to find mutations that are
associated with survival so what I mean
is that we want to identify for example
mutations or genes such that if i
compare the survival of patients that
have a mutation in the gene with the
survival of the patients that do not
have a mutation in the gene the survival
is different so how can I do that well
let's look a bit more closely to what is
actually the survival data that we get
and the survival data is actually made
of two pieces of information for its
patient one is a survival time the time
to the event for the patient and the
second piece of information is the
censoring information they tell us if
the survival time that we have for the
patients is the actual time of the event
for example of the death of the patient
or is just a lower bound for the patient
in that case we say that we have a
censored survivor censored information
so now given the mutation rate and the
survival information how can we identify
the mutations or the genes that are
significantly associated with survival
well by analogy with the case of finding
driver genes in cancer we have thought
from single gene test so I can look at
one specific gene and partition the
patient into the two groups the patient
that do not have a mutation in the gene
and the patient that have a mutation in
the gene I can represent this with a
group label essentially and now de
spliff the patient into the two groups
compared the survivor disturb blue
distribution that I can estimate quite
easily and they use a statistical test
to obtain a p-value that is a measure
the basis of the difference in survival
between the two populations it is
essentially the measure of the
Association of the mutation with
survival
okay so what is this statistical tests
that we are considering one of the
mostly must use statistical tests is the
log-rank test oops take the log-rank
test that is a nonparametric test in the
sense that it doesn't actually consider
the actual times the observed times of
survival so what we do is does we
consider the patient's sorted by
increasing survival time and then all
the information we need to perform a
log-rank test is the group label so to
know if a patient has a mutation in the
genes or not and the censoring vector so
actually since the censoring is fixed
for the entire dataset and now we will
look at different genes what changes is
that the label information so the vector
X of the group labels and what the lock
drank does it just compute a test
statistic so it's just a function of the
data that depends on the group
information and the censoring as I said
we can consider it just as a function of
the group information so we can look at
this for a given gene we can compute a
score and this court that depends on the
group level so the log-rank test do not
go to in too many details or any more
details give us a way to compute the
probability that the statistic that we
observe in the data comes from or
observing a value for the statistic at
least as Extreme as the one that lived
in the data under the null hypothesis of
no difference in survival between the
two populations so the smaller this
probability it is then more unlikely it
is that the difference in survival that
we observe for the two populations is
actually explained by a random ethics
okay so now that we have the log-rank
test what we can do is just perform a
single gene test for the first gene the
single distaste for the second gene and
Sigma gene test for the third gene and
so on for the genes we obtain a p-value
different for each of them then we apply
multiple hypotheses correction and will
obtain a list the tell us which one's of
the genes are significantly associated
with survival in which
answer not so let me at the point to
this this seems all very easy this
approach actually requires the accurate
computation of small probabilities and
so you cannot actually use standard
tools for survival analysis that are
based on the synthetic approximation or
asymptotic distribution for the log-rank
statistic so you need to do something
different from what is for example
implemented in our served if just to
mention a specific software so what
we've done in the past is we have
developed a tool that provides an
accurate approximation of these very
small probabilities that are needed in
case you're texting all possible genes
in the genome okay so now that we have
this test what we can do is take real
data set for example from the TCGA
global multi format which we have
hundreds of samples we take the samples
for which we mutation survival data we
take only the 780 genes that are mutated
in at least three samples and we do this
single gene test what we obtain out of
this is actually there are no genes that
are significantly associated with
survival after the multiple hypotheses
correction so this is actually a common
picture when you look at the data set
from the Cancer Genome Atlas usually
obtained 10 or less a few genes
associated with survival or very often
you don't obtain any gene associated
with survival so why is that well it
might be that there are no mutations or
genes associated with survival but the
one possibility is actually that we need
to look at set of genes and try to
understand if the set of gene is
associated with survival so what do I
mean with this is that for example if I
look at two genes let's say even they
are they make they are interacting genes
on a network for example what I can do I
can partition the patients based on the
mutation status for these two genes so i
can divide the patients into the the
ones that have at least one of the 2 g's
lated and the patients that do not have
any mutation in the genes and now again
I can use the log-rank test to measure
the difference in survival between these
two populations okay this is one when
I'm given the set of genes what if i
want to find the subnetwork these
associated with survival so I'm not
given the set beforehand but I wanted to
find it so maybe I want to identify the
set of genes among all possible jeans or
maybe what I want to do is to restrict
to Aegina interruption network the
problem that I want to solve is given
the mutation data the survival
information and this large gene
interaction network contains tens of
thousands of genes I want to find the
connected sub network restricting maybe
2k genes that has the highest
association with survival as measured by
the log-rank test so this is a
computational problem is not well
formulated yet because I haven't said
what what it means to have the highest
association with survival so the way we
can measure this association for the
log-rank statistic is by defining for a
set of genes its weight as the
normalized log-rank statistic that i
obtained by the group labeled I
described before so i can take the
patient the set a so the set s of jeans
and assign the group label according to
procedure I've said before so I signed 0
if I don't have any mutation in the set
of genes for the patient assigning one
if at least one with the genes is
mutated now they type the group label i
can compute the score for these group
label and that is going to be the score
for my set oh geez okay so now you can
really define a computational problem
that we call the max connected que cette
log-rank problem and it correspond to
identify the sub network of k genes of a
large graph of energies that maximizes
the log-rank statistic or disc or so the
further that we add in a paper that is
going to appear in a reconvert 2016 is
that this problem is np-hard
it is impaired even when we are a strict
two graphs that have only one node with
the high degree and since in biological
networks there are hubs this problem is
np-hard to solve in practice for viola
networks of biological relevance ok so
there are many problems that are mpr
don't graphs in bio for matix but they
are solved anyway and in during these
years many techniques have been used to
solve graph problems and a particularly
technique that it was to interest to us
is the color coding technique that has
been introduced by Allan Houston Zeke in
stock 94 so does the color coding
technique works they say that I have a
graph a network and the one identify sub
network of size 3 what I do is I random
color de Graaff with K colors so in
particular i assign to each vertex in
this graph a random color chosen among
three and why is this a good idea
because once I have a given coloring
finding the highest calorie let the ice
the score in colorful sub graph is easy
the colorful sub graph is a sub graph
that contains all k different colors and
it is connected so for example this sub
graph appear is a colorful sub graph
with three genes so easy means that it
can be done by dynamic programming and
these procedure this dynamic programming
procedure is efficient as long as case
not too large so as it is essentially
log n where n is the number of vertices
in the entire graph yeah what is the
score great question so the score for us
is going to be the log-rank statistic so
here is this problem they also
for I in general no in general it has
been applied to many different scenarios
that are going to present in the next
slide just to mention this core can be
different things for example you can
have a single gene score that represent
some measure for a genie want to
maximize maybe the sum of this course or
you may just be interested in finding
certain structures so you actually don't
have a score for the gene you wanna
maybe understand if there is a simple
path of a certain length K and so you're
looking for a colorful sub graph that is
a simple path but the main point is that
you can find let's say I scoring or
colorful subgraphs the type certain
properties efficiently when K is not too
large ok just to further but that's all
cramming to be used here you cannot have
any score right you need the score to be
additive or very pointed at I go to
mention later yeah you need the score to
be additive so old on that for two more
slides I think then I'm going to go back
to that ok so in this approach now we
have obtained one random coloring of the
graph and the problem is that maybe your
iced scoring sub graph like the one the
test the highest association with
survival may not be colorful in the
coloring you have chosen but it's easy
to see that if you repeat this enough
times then actually in at least one
iteration your sub graph will be color
ok color coding has being used a lot in
bioinformatics in for many different
applications and in particular I think
it has been used at least by Rho dead
jank Iman and Ron there are many of the
people inside in this room that we use
color coding and so what we have done
with my student Tommy Hanson that is
currently the university of south and
Denmark is to build on top of the color
coding procedure a method that
identifies the
sub networks with mutations associated
with survival by taking a gene
interaction network run a diffusion
process on the network so that we
capture interactions that are not just
direct interaction and then we combine
these network with mutation day 10
survival information using the color
coding a color coding based diagram we
identify sub networks that have high
death are I scoring where I scoring
means if they have a high normalized
loegering statistic once we have
identified these sub networks we know
that they have a I log-rank statistic so
it means they will show a significant
difference probably in survival between
the patients that have a mutation in the
sub network and the patients that do not
have mutation in the sub network however
we need to perform a permutation test to
make sure that what we are finding is
not just an effect of random
fluctuations in the graph and I can talk
more about that if you have questions
about it okay as pointed out by JP when
I before said that given a coloring of
the graph finding the best color food
sub graph is easy I was actually
cheating in the sense that this is true
only when the score is additive so only
when the score for a set of genes is
given by the sum of the scores of the
single geez so what does this imply for
our problem well our score is not
additive that means that color coding
may not find the optimal solution
actually in the Recon paper we have the
proof that with the addition of few
vertices in the worst case we will not
identify the optimal solution so why
does it make sense to use color coding
to solve our problem because the data
that we get is not worth case and so
what we proved is that under certain
assumptions for mutations and the
relation with survival that we think are
reasonable and mostly they means that
the mutate
most of the mutations are placed
independently of survival under this
assumption if you are given enough
samples then our agron nomas will
identify the optimal solution so we like
to actually identify the sub network
that tests the highest association with
survival okay so Tommy has implemented
desire him and we try to we tested it on
data first one simulated a tendon on
cancer data from the TCGA so simulate
the data what we have done is we assume
that there is a set D of genes that have
association with survival the set is not
too large in particular for these
experiments i think it was around 10 and
what we have is that each of the genes
is mutated with a certain probability p
in the set in a set of patients that
have low survival instead for all genes
they also have random mutations that
represent passenger mutations or
mutations that are independent of
survival and then we run norma's and
compared the solution the best solution
found by nomas with the subnetwork d
that we planted in the data so what we
are shown in this graph is the
probability that the solution found by
nomas corresponds to the planted
solution as a function of the number of
samples that we are using in the data so
as we can see for example for this red
line that corresponds to the case of
when there is not a strong association
between the set da survival the
probability that our eigen identifies
the subnetwork associated with survival
is not the time but when the number of
samples increases or when the
association between the set and survival
desire our ibrehem finds the up the
actual planted solution with probability
that is getting closer to one in
moreover simulations show that even when
we do not identify the optimal solution
the solution we find contains many of
the genes that are actually associated
with survival
and since we are using a color coding
actually we don't have only to look at
the highest score resolution you obtain
other solutions for free from this
dynamic programming table and so what we
have is that we if we look for example
in the top 10 solutions identified we
identify the ice core solution with the
probability that is at least fifty
percent for our four sample sizes deter
around what we have for glioblastoma
multiforme and we'd provider probability
when we have more samples okay so then
we test enormous on cancer data from the
Cancer Genome Atlas and we use the
network that we used in the hot neck to
paper as well and we compelling
particular nomas with other approaches
particularly compared with greedy
algorithms that have been used before to
identify sub-networks associated with
survival and these are actually greedy
algorithms that are inspired by standard
strategy standard greedy method on
networks and also we compared with
metals in which the score now is just an
additive score on the genes so this is
essentially an approximation of the
score so what we have when we are normal
is that if we look at the specific data
set for example and these are the two
tales of the log-rank we can focus on
one of them the score of the solution
the top solution identified by norma's
is represented here in black while the
solution represent found by the other
metals are represented with the other
lines and we can see the enormous always
identifies better solutions sometimes
the other metals identify solutions that
are quite close but sometimes they are
actually very different so actually our
method does identify better solutions
aurea data okay now in the few minutes
that I have left and going to show you
two sub networks that are identified on
one on glabrous automotive former and
another one in AML and this is to be
considered essentially working progress
so this is a sub network that is
association with low survival
in the sense that if you look at the
patients that have increased a mutation
in this network the survival
distribution for these patients is lower
than the survival distribution of the
patients with no mutation in the sub
network this is a representation of the
mutations and the different genes in the
network actually see that since the
patients are sorted by increasing
survival time most of the mutations in
the subnetwork appear in the for
patients that have low survival time so
this is significant according to a
permutation of p value so it is highly
unlikely that you would identify such a
set of genes in the network and the most
important thing is that well first one
of the genes cdkn2a is a gene that is
known to be important for global thermal
t form and none of the genes a
significant association with survival
when considered in isolation as we said
before so the entire site is
significantly associated with survival
why none of the single gene sees then as
I said this is working progress so the
figure that I've now for AML is not as
nice as they want that I had before but
this is a subnetwork with eight genes
identified on AML again none of the
genes a significant association with
survival and the p-value is still
significant for the entire sub network
disab Network shows mutations that are
associated with increased survival and
in fact what we have done in this data
set we have also included fusion fusion
genes that are important for AML and
there are pml and my age 11 in the
subnetwork are actually fusion genes
that have been reported to be associated
with the favorable cytogenetic risk in
AML okay so with this I conclude and I
want to just thank the collaborators a
brown that have been involved in the
metas that I've talked the beginning by
Raphael a loofah max leiserson and
shinta whew and I want also to
acknowledge my student Tommy Hanson that
is the one that has done most of the
work for Derek on 2016 paper thank you
questions so you skipped over the part
about censoring that isn't it true that
if you knew the true survival time with
the censored patients that would alter
the Privy ordering in assault in your
drink I'm not sure of significant that
might be what I can tell you is that
actually the log-rank and they survive
the test for the statistical test for
survival analysis have been designed so
to take care of the fact that there is
censoring and censoring is a is
affecting large proportion of the
patient and one of the assumptions that
is made by this method is that censoring
is essentially independent of the
survival time so that what you get is a
you know the two things are not
correlated then so the statistic or you
can obtain a nice distribution well not
the two things I think may be different
i'm not sure i haven't tried that there
may be something interesting to try
other your connectivity constraint so if
you go back to slides to the module
t-shirt yeah this one for asus yeah
ubiquitin ubc as a super high degree so
it's kind of like a hot and i was
wondering what are those tend to be more
over-represented in your solutions they
don't tend to be over-represented our
solution so we don't get all labs in
here and this but you are right that is
a habit is degree i think in our diffuse
night target is degree probably 400
something that's why we use the
permutation our p-value to try to make
sure that what you are getting is just
not a random set of genes around a high
degree note for question quick one and
so if you look at safety to the caller
caller you randomized algorithm so this
sub optimal solutions what do they look
like are a much different or did I
sensor the p-values if you just look at
it people I so like
that's a great today oh that's a great
question they tend to overlap a lot in
the top ones what I'm showing here just
the top ones and we've actually I is
easy to extend the permutation tests to
take care of the entire distribution but
that's a great question you can get many
solutions that are actually very similar
and as I said this is working progress
in one of the things can you summarize
all the solutions that you get I didn't
really get what the score is you said it
has to be edited so okay no no so the
score is not additive our score is the
log-rank statistic the normalized
version that is not additive at all so
so in the worst case the color coding
does not identify the optimal solution
okay so if you get worst case data you
can or let's say say differently you can
build an example where using color
coding you will not get the optimal
solution but what we proved is that if
the data comes from a distribution that
we think is reasonable then actually if
you have enough samples what you will
get out of the color coding technique is
the optimal solution dynamic programming
yes is a dynamic programming and there
are few things that we do in the color
coding part to speed up a bit compared
to other to the standard application of
color coding I can talk more about that
video after maybe very long step
this comes with this requirement that
you want to have a connected subgraph in
the protein-protein interaction network
you have a very nice computational
problem you can I was wondering about
the biological background because I I
mean here you're not looking for a
mutually exclusive pathway genes in
completely different passed away and
there then associated with survival yeah
so that's a that's a great point I guess
the motivation here was to try to look
for pathways so that's the entire part
two is associated with survival so it
might be that you have a mechanism
essentially that is associated with
survival not a single genes in there but
actually one of the directions we are
looking at is to find genes that may be
in different parts of the network and
still be associated with survival
because it might be that not all the
genes in the pathways are actually have
the same effect on survival let's say so
you're absolutely right this was a
design attempt to trying to find
pathways or group of interrupting genes
that are associated with surviving a
great discussion topic too so not just
for this but in many inspectors that and
I've been a culprit myself why might we
insist on connectivity in what way do we
identify a pathway maybe one day we
should question the assumptions but we
have I was thinking that maybe the
discussions after narrative could be
about networks here the figur start this
morning and
see more never stuff would be more talks
on networks but you know sort of what
are the dangers of using versus various
networks what do we know what we don't
know you know what are the assumptions
that go into Katherine he'll be one let
me mention let me just mention even if
you take the network away steal em yeah
that's a great point so I guess a
general question is if you have a
phenotypic connotation or different type
of annotations about the therapy can you
do a better job and for some of the data
sets at least there is such a notation
so I think we can do a better job but is
an open direction session let's thank
love you again